every year the pantone color institute
announces the color of the year as a
trend-setting concept that influences us
in lots of ways from the clothes we wear
to the beauty products we use to the way
we decorate our homes
and this year they actually had two
colors
take the top spot looks like even
pantone
shook things up in 2020. so
check it out the winners are
ultimate gray a neutral that goes back
to basics
and illuminating a lemony yellow that
evokes
basically the hope of a brighter 20 twin
yeah i love yellow it also happens to be
the signature color of our show so
that's lucky yeah right that worked out
well
okay so now we're going to show you some
ways to incorporate these colors into
your living space check them out
oh dougie you're a whole other pantone
color
um okay well dougie is representing the
throw pillow because
that's a fantastic way to have a neutral
chair
but get a quick pop of color so that it
doesn't override the room
this pillow and pillowcases actually
is like amazon for about 1998 so that's
a fantastic
way to get a little moment all right
this rug i really like because let's
face it
a colorful rug as fabulous as it may be
life weather kids dogs it's gonna get
dirty immediately
so i really like this gray um
it's also a really nice sort of like
coarse sisal fabric it's a decent size
we got it on ikea for a hundred dollars
and gray is just good
on the floor now one thing that sarah
and i
uh we do these segments together um
she's a designer she's my partner in
crime
she brought up a fantastic point which
is the scale of art
when you get a bigger piece it just
looks more expensive
it just looks more luxe the more
diminutive
it doesn't really necessarily mean a
price but
big is big and in this case i think it
really
shows nicely and we got this at home
goods for 59
so yellow white and gray paint we went
with a light gray here because i think i
felt like and she did too white was too
stark this light gray really brings it
all together
and doesn't have sort of another color
entering the picture
i always think pops of black it's not
the way i used to design
but something about as i get older pops
of black
are just androgynous neutral and chic
unto themselves and um i
love these colors because i do
think gray is a very safe tone gosh i'm
wearing it on my pants
but i think that the yellow really
is something that evokes mood and i
think that's why we gravitated towards
it on the show
because we like the sunny side upness of
life
and clearly pantone picks something
that i think just we want colors
to make us feel something i also work
with anna and francesca and all our
flower brands
and anna always says color changes
everything and it does i will look at
something it'll be a certain color i'm
like i don't think i like it
we'll change the color and i'll be like
i love it
color has such a profound effect on our
psyches our moods
and our life it can also make things
look bigger and smaller
so really the possibilities with color
are absolutely endless um
i really like this room we were able to
put it together very affordably there's
companies that have an average can of
paint for
ten dollars paint is something
everybody's feels like a real commitment
to
i say play paint big swatches not small
also look at them at night and in the
day they're going to be very different
and just play you can always paint over
it it's not wallpaper it's not molding
go for it express yourself and also
for something like this a chair a table
lamp i like to go on overstock.com they
have a
fabulous amount of options with really
decent prices
so here's our representation of the two
pantone colors of the year
in your home and in your life
[Music]
you